the movie begins inside a South Korean
flight where all the people are
terrified due to a mysterious reason
several passengers including the main
pilot have already died in a brutal way
the plane which is heading to Hawaii
soon reaches the U.S Mainland and
everyone on board becomes relieved
thinking their nightmare has finally
come to an end however little did they
know that they're in for one of the most
terrorizing rides in the history of
Aviation the U.S government immediately
denies their entry and sends them away
left with no options the flight returns
back to Korea but surprisingly at the
airport thousands of people are
protesting against their Landing this
forces the plane to divert its route and
ask for help from neighboring countries
like China and Japan sadly instead of
help all they receive is threats from
several fighter planes to leave their
airspace at last the flight gets stuck
in limbo with virtually no country in
the world accepting them then we are
taken back to eight hours earlier where
it all started at the Incheon
International Airport we see a shady
looking guy named Ryu wandering around
soon he heads to a ticket counter and
asks the receptionist which flight has
the most passengers however she refuses
to answer because it's against airport
policy and his private information
meanwhile a man named Park and his
daughter Sue Min are waiting in line to
board a plane Sue heads off by herself
to the bathroom but the women's line is
too long so she uses the men's instead
Ryu is alone in the men's bathroom and
when he is all alone he makes a small
cut inside his armpit and inserts a
capsule after he Stitches the wound and
applies the dressing he notices someone
looking at him from inside one of the
toilet stalls Ryu approaches the stall
but suddenly Park enters the bathroom
looking for his daughter it turns out
that Sue is the one who is spying on Ryu
and the two leave to board the plane
elsewhere a police officer Eno is on a
call with his wife who's about to board
a plane to Hawaii for vacation
unfortunately Eno has got some extra
work so he cannot join her later when he
reaches his workplace the police
department he receives a video from some
kids in which one of their neighbors is
threatening to hijack a play Lane the
other officers simply take this as a
prank and decide to ignore it but Eno is
skeptical after a bit of deliberation he
eventually decides to pay the kids a
visit to get a better understanding of
the situation it turns out that the man
in the video is actually their neighbor
suspicious Eno and another officer
investigate the man's flat and to their
horror they find a dead human body in
the corner of his room tightly wrapped
in plastic back at the airport park and
his daughter Sue are about to board the
plane when they are confronted by the
strange man from earlier Ryu he starts
asking them personal questions and also
about their destination as expected Park
becomes Furious and threatens the man to
go away but unfortunately Ryu finds out
that the father-daughter Duo is heading
to Hawaii so he books a ticket for the
same place shortly after going through
airport security Ryu is questioned about
a metal device in his bag but he
configures it and verifies that it's
just his asthma inhaler the movie then
shifts to the plane where Ryu Park Sue
and other passengers including Eno's
wife have just boarded after the
announcements the plane takes off and
shortly after Ryu heads into the
bathroom there he removes his wound
dressing and takes out the capsule he
then places the capsule in his asthma
inhaler which turns out to be a spray
container after this he sprays the
entire room with the strange substance
whilst covering his own mouth and nose
meanwhile in the suspect's apartment a
CSI agent concludes that the cause of
the death of the body was poison another
agent locates a box full of videotapes
and upon watching they find a man
putting a strange powder in a container
full of experimental rats surprisingly
just after minutes The Rats start dying
gruesomely while spouting blood as the
agents watch in horror they conclude
that the powder is in fact a virus as
the rats that did not come in contact
with the powder also died furthermore
the dead body also tests positive for
the same virus putting all agents on a
high alert back in the plane Ryu exits
the bathroom and sees Sue waiting in
line but as the little girl opens the
door another man hurriedly enters the
bathroom saying it is urgent then Ria
Whispers something in Sue's ear and
heads to a seat meanwhile the man who
entered the bathroom notices some powder
in the air and starts coughing he
immediately complains about it to the
flight Hostess and unfortunately she
also enters the contaminated room in the
meantime a man is watching the plane
threat video which draws Park's
attention on a closer look he notices
that the perpetrator in the video
resembles Ryu scared he looks for his
daughter and finds her waiting outside
the bathroom then he approaches the
flight attendants and shows them the
video but they are not sure if it is
real however Park is adamant in his
theory so he asks his daughter to speak
up with a terrified look the little girl
says that Ryu has smuggled something
into the plane in his armpit she also
reveals that he whispered to her that
everyone on this plane is going to die
hearing all of this one of the flight
attendants finally confronts Ryu and
asks for his ID the latter takes out his
visiting card and claims to be a
scientist who is going to Honolulu to
attend a conference however when the
attendant presses him for more
information he refuses in the meantime
Eno and a few officers rushed to the
airport and find an ID match with the
person in the video the perpetrator was
revealed to be none other than Ryu
himself realizing that his wife is also
on the same flight Eno is left
speechless in the plane the man who
entered the bathroom starts to get
rashes on his skin all of a sudden one
of his eyeballs bursts and he vomits
blood before falling to the ground this
causes a Ruckus inside the plane and
when a physician passenger examines the
man she confirms that he has died
because of this park immediately accuses
Ryu of murdering the man there are three
pilots on board the main pilot Captain
Juan co-pilot Choi and another pilot
Jang the main pilot and choir in the
cockpit while Jang is taking a rest
before his scheduled shift soon the
pilot in the cockpit become aware about
the situation on board and they also
learn about ryu's involvement from
Mission Control when the situation
starts getting out of hand the co-pilot
Choi exits the cockpit he finds Park and
Ryu tussling among a terrified audience
and immediately breaks them up it turns
out that Park and Choi recognize each
other after calming everyone down Choi
asks Ryu for his ID but the latter
pretends to be American he then attempts
to run away to the cockpit but the past
centers managed to get a hold of him
unfortunately before he is restrained
Ryu takes out his spray and spreads it
everywhere afterwards Choi informs the
main pilot Captain Juan that everyone is
sick including the other co-pilot Zhang
hence he decides not to enter the
cockpit to prevent risking Captain
Juan's life elsewhere government
officials and experts discuss the
situation including transport Minister
Kim and Eno's team after thorough
investigation it is revealed that Rio
was the head of microbiology at the
multinational firm brecom sadly even
after numerous calls the company refuses
to cooperate stating that they have no
relations to the hijacking now with time
running out Eno suggests the officials
try to obtain the spray's antidote from
Ryu before more people lose their lives
the officials agree and soon Choice
starts a conversation with Ryu as the
governmental listens in however instead
of helping the psychopath keeps on
saying that everyone on the plane will
die Joy tries forcing him for a
treatment but all of a sudden Ryu spouts
blood indicating that he too has been
infected suddenly the plane starts to
free fall and it is revealed that the
main pilot has died after somehow being
exposed to the virus passengers fly
everywhere and the plane starts to
spiral down the other co-pilot Zhang who
has also become sick somehow makes his
way to the cockpit and tries to pull the
steering up but to no avail fortunately
before the plane crashes to the Ground
Park also arrives at the cockpit and
pulls the speed break up hence bringing
the situation under control soon Choi
also reaches the cockpit and notices
Park in his seat as the two speak we get
to know that Park was once a famous
pilot but he had to quit after an
accident meanwhile jiang's condition
begins to worsen so Choi who is the only
unaffected pilot mans the aircraft on
the other hand Ryu passes away while a
passenger in the plane records the
terror around him and sends it to the
reporters in the next scene Eno suspects
that ryu's ex-employer bricom has
something to hide as they are refusing
to cooperate hence he decides to go to
its headquarters to talk to the director
shortly after he reaches the place and
tries to force his way in but the guards
immediately block him saying saying that
a warrant is required hearing this he
know becomes enraged and starts a fight
with the guards a reporter captures the
altercation and posts it on the internet
back inside the plane people start
fainting and dying one after another
therefore the staff starts separating
people the ones who have symptoms of the
virus go to the tail of the plane while
the others go to the front Park who is
unaffected heads to the front with his
daughter but a man stops them because
Sue has developed blisters it turns out
that the little girl has eczema but the
angry mob has mistaken it for the virus
not wanting the tension to rise anymore
Sue requests her dad to take her to the
tail and park reluctantly obliges in
this way several hours of Terror have
passed on the plane and they have almost
reached the U.S the officials in Korea
are positive that their American
counterparts will take care of the
situation and rescue the passengers
however they couldn't be any more wrong
acting pilot Choi suddenly receives a
message from the U.S Mission Control
stating that the landing permission is
denied as nothing is known about the
virus and it Bears too much of a risk
this leaves the pilot and the government
officers Dev stated left with no options
Choi is ordered to fly the plane back to
Korea the news spreads like wildfire and
all of the passengers fall into Despair
and lose all hope of surviving luckily
Eno gets a call from a brecom employee
after his fight with the guards goes
viral she reveals that a fellow brecom
employee named seung-hoon fled the HQ as
soon as he saw the news this indicates
that he might have conspired with Ryu
the police rushed to the man's address
which soon turns into a desperate Chase
unfortunately Eno and another officer
get into a car crash leaving them with
minor injuries but shockingly instead of
running away the suspect sung helps them
later Sun claims that he was actually
tricked by Ryu and that he is not a
co-conspirator he tells the police that
the highly infectious virus's name is
SC1 and that brecom acquired it
illegally he also reveals that some
researchers got exposed to the virus
resulting in their untimely deaths
however one survived and said that Rio
had intentionally exposed them to the
virus afraid of the repercussions the
company covered up this incident by
firing Ryu after getting relieved from
company Ryu contacted sung and tricked
him into passing a sample to him to
clear his name hearing all this he still
banged up Eno tries to contact the
researcher who had survived the virus
meanwhile on the plane the chief
attendant runs into park inside the
medical room and asks him why he quit
being a pilot reluctantly he reveals
that during his last flight one of the
engines caught fire therefore he made an
emergency landing despite the
disapproval from the control tower
because of the quick thinking all the
passengers were saved however two flight
attendants died they were engulfed by
the fire while helping the passengers
Escape one of them is revealed to be
choi's wife just then inside the cockpit
Choi begins to vomit blood now with all
the pilots either sick or dead he
requests Park to help him co-pilot the
plane as the latter is the only
passenger who has flying experience
although the previous incident has left
Park's guard he agrees to help
immediately a few hours later Eno meets
the Survivor who is still hospitalized
to this day he shows her a picture of
the corpse from earlier and she
recognizes the virus as the same one she
is exposed to shortly after transport
Minister Kim finds out that briecom has
both the vaccine and the antivirus so
she heads to the HQ and forces them to
cooperate later Kim thanks Eno for his
efforts and the news channels report
that brecom will provide the vaccine and
Antivirus free of charge much to the
relief of the passengers however Choi
continues to spout blood so he decides
to abruptly land in Narita Airport Japan
he issues an emergency declaration and
prepares to descend but the Japanese
control tower orders him to leave their
airspace however Choi refuses the order
forcing the Japanese Air Force to appear
with warning shots soon a Japanese
battle plane arrives from the opposite
direction at full speed the two planes
almost Collide and ultimately Choi is
forced to lift his plane upwards because
of the altercation he becomes exhausted
and Fades so park quickly takes his
place and flies the plane away from
Japan in no time the Japanese officials
face heavy criticism from the media and
human rights groups all over the world
the country is forced to give an
explanation and their prime minister
eventually announces that they turned
away the plane because the virus has a
much shorter incubation period than
originally predicted this means that the
antivirus and vaccine may not even work
as a result Korean politicians also
start to worry and the voices of people
opposing the plane landing in Korea
begin to get stronger determined to save
everyone on that plane Eno rushes to the
quarantine facility made in Seoul
airport and offers to be an experimental
subject for the antivirus he forcefully
injects the virus into himself and
allows the researchers to test the
antivirus on him soon Kim finds out
about this and when she reaches the
quarantine facility he knows already
writhing in pain to everyone's dismay
the antivirus doesn't work meanwhile
numerous violent protests break
throughout Korea that oppose the plane
landing hence the government orders the
Korean Air Force to stop the infected
plane so that peace is maintained on
land the news quickly spreads on all TV
channels and the passengers on board
also catch wind of this through their
phones realizing that risking their
loved ones and other people is not worth
it the passengers make peace with their
fate with this park contacts the control
tower and broadcasts a message he says
that everyone on the plane is thankful
for the great support but they have
collectively decided against Landing as
it is the best solution for everyone
before hanging up Park also mentions
that he will cut all radio
communications and that this will be
their last interaction soon the
passengers also begin to call their
loved ones for one last time after a
while they see the plane flying above
them heading to the nearby sea just when
everyone is almost given up Kim hears
Eno's Vital Signs monitor starting to
beep as she stares at him with hope he
suddenly wakes up the antivirus has
miraculously worked and Eno urges the
authorities to call the plane back
wasting no time the control tower tries
to contact the plane but its radio has
been turned off as a last resort they
tell the families to contact the
passengers via phone the plan works and
when the people on board receive the
message they scream with joy Park
promptly turns the radio back on and the
plane heads for a nearby Air Base
unfortunately the plane is low on fuel
and soon it loses its power now the only
option is to Glide down into a small Air
Base but the problem is that the plane's
acceleration is so high that it may risk
skidding Off The Runway but fortunately
this is where Park's experience comes in
he immediately circles the area a few
times to reduce momentum and at the
perfect time begins The Descent soon the
wheels hit the ground and the plane
rattles however it lands safely much to
everyone's relief several days pass by
and park goes to a get-together of the
survivors there he meets co-pilot Choi
and Eno sadly the virus has left him
permanently paralyzed but his heroism
saved the life of hundreds or possibly
thousands the movie ends as Eno slightly
holds his head up and smiles at Park the
moral of today's story is that butting
the line to take a piss is bad news for
everyone subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching